who exactly are the Council of Kings
what do they really want and why is Bill
Murray in this movie Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania has left us with a ton
of questions and we want answers the
whole plot of quantumania kicks off
because Cassie Lang designs a device
that can peer down into the quantum
realm and map it she tells her dad that
the invention which she built with Hank
and Hope's help is based on Hank's
journals Cassie describes the device as
being like a satellite while Hank
Compares it to the Hubble telescope only
designed to map subatomic universes
instead of space whatever the exact
details it's clearly meant to be a
window not a gate like a satellite for
deep space or the ocean
but
iguana however its signal is strong
enough for Kang to lock onto it from the
quantum realm in only a matter of
seconds and pull the entire family down
to his level the question is how King is
clearly unable to leave the quantum
realm without fully reactivating his
Multiverse drive that drives the plot of
the whole film but he somehow is able to
bring people down to him which doesn't
seem all that different from getting out
is it Cassie's device that makes this
possible for something that is supposed
to just be a scanner it sure seems to do
a lot more than that
perhaps the most perplexing part of
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania is that
the film doesn't really explain how the
quantum realm actually works that's
partially because it's weird temporal
properties makes it impossible for us
mere humans to understand but the film
rarely even tries to address the rules
of the world in a consistent way for
instance when the Lang gang is pulled
into the tiny Dimension by Kang Hank's
technologically savvy ants are taken
with them they return in the film's
final act as an advanced super species
having supposedly hit a temporal anomaly
on their way down that allowed them to
live through thousands of years in a
single second while this is totally
feasible within our understanding of the
quantum realm it seems odd that it only
happens to the ants the five main
characters all land in the same temporal
moment and in relatively close proximity
krylar has aged the same amount as Janet
has since her departure and when the
crew escapes at the end no significant
time is passed on Earth compare that to
Avengers end game where five Earth years
pass in the blink of an eye for Scott
that must have been a very long
that's just it
wasn't
for me it was five hours again this all
technically makes sense but why does the
quantum realm only do weird Time stuff
when it's convenient for the story a
consistent set of rules would help this
feel less like a contrived plot device
then again maybe it's just consistently
inconsistent see
one and realm aren't like they are up
here everything is unpredictable
when Scott and Company arrive in the
quantum realm they find a land that
could fit into nearly any sci-fi or
fantasy Universe there are various alien
species weird Technologies and bizarre
flora and fauna just on a subatomic
scale but none of it feels particularly
unique overall it comes across more like
a far away planet heck it even has beer
since the quantum realm is so similar to
Earth it's not surprising to see humans
walking around but it should be yet
while much of the sentient life in and
around Axia is otherworldly there are
plenty of people who just look like well
people Hank brings this up at one point
to krylar who gives a gross non-answer
after that it's never brought up again
so where do these humans come from are
they descended from other Earth people
who were also trapped in the quantum
realm the movie has no interest in the
answer
if you're a fan of the comics you
probably weren't too surprised by Cassie
Lang's superhero transformation in
quantumania she's fought against
numerous threats on The Illustrated page
operating under the moniker's stinger
and stature among others and even
joining the Young Avengers at one point
she seems well on her way down the same
path in the MCU with quantumania
revealing her own unique size-changing
Ant-Man suit but while she mentions
having a suit early on she doesn't
actually use it until gentura's Camp is
being attacked almost halfway through
the movie why doesn't she put it on
during her fall into the quantum realm
to protect herself like Scott and hope
do why not put it on when her dad is
being attacked by a giant alien squid
why not give herself the best chance of
survival and put the dang suit on it
seemed like the suit was saved to be a
big dramatic reveal but it was a real
head scratcher instead momentum right
jump tap
you see what I did no you're like this
small in a movie filled with
broccoli-headed aliens and sentient ooze
the seemingly ordinary krylar still
manages to be one of the most perplexing
characters his mere inclusion in
quantumania feels like little more than
a wink and Nod to the audience saying
look it's Bill Murray remember Bill
Murray these days audiences would likely
respond with yes he's the guy with all
kinds of misconduct allegations against
him going back decades it's a baffling
time to write a character who's so
transparently just a vehicle for the
actor kreiler features in only one scene
and yet he gets almost as many lines as
gentura and the character just doesn't
add up kryler was apparently one of
Janet's main allies in her freedom
fighting campaign against Kang and even
her lover but now he's a lord working
for Kang why is he so important in
Kang's regime now why wouldn't Kang have
just killed him it seems like the
character's only purpose is to shoehorn
in a cameo from an actor who these days
comes with a ton of baggage
after dodging questions from her family
for roughly half the movie Janet Van
Dyne finally explains her history with
Kang we learned from her that he was
cast out of the Multiverse by the other
Kang variants and exiled specifically to
the quantum realm since it exists
outside of both regular space and the
time stream later Kang provides some
illumination on why he was banished in
the first place he claims to have seen
the end of time and how his variants
destroyed the Multiverse something
hinted at by another Kang variant he who
remains in Loki season 1. but when Janet
gains access to his mind through his
ship's neural link she sees that this
Kang has also wiped out entire timelines
the same thing he's accusing his
Brethren of doing so what actually
happened between this particular king
and the others was he a threat to them
because he wanted to usurp their power
or could he actually be trying to save
the Multiverse from the other kings like
he says we suspect Marvel is going to
spend the rest of phases 5 and 6 giving
us the answer much of the responsibility
for what happens in Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania can be left squarely at
Janet van dyne's feet for not telling
anyone the truth about her time in the
quantum realm it becomes clear that she
didn't want to tell anyone because she
carries a great deal of guilt for her
role in helping Kane conquer Axia
unfortunately quantumania has Janet
withholding so much information for so
long that it becomes tiresome there are
plenty of opportunities for her to
explain the king's situation before she
does but she just keeps repeating that
there isn't enough time so when she does
finally tell them about Kang we have to
wonder does she really tell them
everything or is there more she's still
hiding the quantum realm is a strange
place and she was there for a very long
time it's possible that Kang isn't the
only dangerous person she encountered
additionally she saw into his brain at
one point King himself even asks her
what exactly she saw it's a question we
want answered too
although the quantum realm is described
as being almost infinite in size
quantumania only takes place in a small
corner of it the city of Axia and the
surrounding area is where Kang has built
his Empire and conveniently it's also
where all five of our protagonists land
this is a very different portrait of the
quantum realm from what's shown in
earlier MCU movies and it begs the
question does it all look like the
little we see in quantumania the short
answer is no by its very nature the
quantum realm is Fantastical and
ever-changing but quantumania doesn't do
a very good job of showing us that
diverse landscape the bits we do visit
seem pretty similar to our own world
there are cities deserts forests and
bars it's a lot like California
hopefully we'll get to return to the
quantum realm in some future MCU project
and see more of the crazy stuff we
didn't get this time around
okay let's talk one more time about
Cassie's mystery machine at the end of
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania Scott
and hope are able to get Hank Janet and
Cassie home through a portal created by
King's Multiverse drive but to defeat
him they have to overload the drive thus
closing their way back for a moment it
looks like they might be trapped in the
quantum realm forever but only for a
moment using the device she shows off at
the beginning of the film Cassie quickly
reopens the portal allowing hope and
Scott to escape but how Kang and Janet
say multiple times that the only way for
him to escape is by repairing the core
of his Multiverse drive so how is Cassie
still able to open a Gateway after the
drive has seemingly been destroyed
especially using a scanning satellite
even after the second portal opens Scott
and hope completely undersell it as if
they already knew they still had a way
home if only we understood as well as
they seem to in his final showdown with
Kang Scott overloads the Multiverse
Drive core using a handful of Pim
particle discs King desperately tries to
stop the device from going ballistic but
it's too late what happens next though
is a lot more bewildering King appears
to be vaporized out of existence by the
drive later in the film's mid-credit
scene the Council of Kings claims that
he's dead but is this true it's unclear
what exactly Scott does to the
Multiverse drive and it's equally
unclear what it does to Kang since the
device is capable of jumping across
realities it's conceivable that King was
simply transported somewhere else it's
also possible that he was just trunk
down even further by the Pim particles
given they spent an entire movie
developing this Kang variant in
particular it seems too soon to write
him off as dead
Midway through the credits for Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania is a brief
Glimpse at what the other kings of the
Multiverse are up to the scene follows
three main variants an imperial looking
Kang who seems to lead the meeting and
resembles the comic book character
immortus another addressed as a pharaoh
who may be Kang's first iteration in the
comics ramatut and a third who looks
robotic as if from a distant future the
king who looks like a mortise says that
the exiled variant is dead but that he
is concerned about an unspecified them
by which he seems to mean Heroes like
Scott and the Avengers to address this
perceived threat the lead variant has
summoned the Council of Kings in another
scene right out of the comics there are
a ton of questions here from who these
variants really are to what they'll do
next both the exiled Kang and he who
remains from Loki season 1 have claimed
that the Kane Collective will bring
about the end of all things considering
Marvel has already announced Avengers
the Kang Dynasty for 2025. it seems
these at least are questions they are
planning to answer
after the Council of Kang scene
quantumania has one more surprise a
post-credits tease for Loki season 2.
the brief clip shows Loki and Mobius his
ally in the time variance Authority
attending an exposition of some kind in
what looks like the 19th century a king
variant named Victor timely yet another
version from the comics appears on stage
2 philosophies about time but we don't
see enough of the show to know what he's
actually up to even more intriguing is
how and why Loki and Mobius are there
especially together after learning about
Kang at the end of Loki season 1 the god
of Mischief seemed bent on stopping his
rise but when he returns to the TVA at
the end of that season his whole
timeline has been Rewritten and Mobius
doesn't even know who he is that
suggests that this scene may take place
Midway through Loki season 2. someone is
coming countless different versions of a
very dangerous person and they're all
set on war we need to prepare with no
firm release date announced yet for Loki
season 2 though fans may just have to
build their own time machine to find out
what happens next
[Music]